a picture is worth a thousand words and
Demi Lovato's latest post on the gram
has Love written all over it it feels so
good in a birthday tribute to boyfriend
Jude's Demi writes I couldn't be more in
love with your gorgeous funny sexy
talented self I've waited my whole life
to find you you're a literal dream come
true
[Applause]
[Music]
and now a source is opening up to E.T
about the couple's romance explaining
Damian juts are doing great they're very
in love and enjoying their time together
jute wants what's best for her and
everyone sees that
our source also says jutz gets the stamp
of approval from Demi's family and
friends who think the musicians made a
good match
the source adds that Demi's in a great
season of life she's sober living a
healthy lifestyle exercising going to
therapy and very in tune with herself
saying true to who I am growing finding
my own voice is was really important to
me and now now I understand that I am in
control of my life I make my own
decisions and I'm My Own Boss
went public with their romance last year
two years after Demi's engagement to Max
Eric ended jutz wrote songs for her last
album including substance
[Music]
it was front and center for Demi's big
30th birthday celebration
at the time chutes wrote on Instagram on
the luckiest schmuck in the world
because I get to call you mine making
you laugh has become my new obsession
[Applause]
it's the best it's going into you know
the era of being so sure of yourself
[Music]
foreign